[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en el
flujo de las migraciones aquí en la
Unión Europea después de las últimas
tragedias que han acontecido en el mar
Mediterráneo para ello nos acompañan en
este estudio Alexandra Castro Es doctor
en derecho y consultora en temas
migratorios bienvenida Muchas gracias
fundadora del gabinete faro para de
consejo para migrantes y refugiados en
Francia y además es premio gran público
ONU mujeres Francia de 2021 bienvenida
Muchas gracias Carlos y además nos
acompaña en dúples nuestra corresponsal
en Bruselas Esther Herrera Buenos días
Hola Buenos días
por estar aquí gracias
el cementerio del Mediterráneo hoy
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
en menos de 15 días varias embarcaciones
repletas de migrantes a náufragado en el
Mediterráneo el caso más grave fue el
hundimiento de un barco con más de 700
migrantes a bordo provenientes
principalmente de Pakistán Egipto y
Siria el 15 de junio frente a las costas
griegas el hundimiento del barco se
cobró al menos 78 vidas en lo que sigue
siendo uno de los peores desastres
migratorios de los últimos años cuatro
días después el 19 de junio otra
embarcación con migrantes a bordo que se
dirigía a las Islas Canarias naufrago en
la frontera euroafricana cerca de
Marruecos el mar del Sáhara occidental
es otra de las rutas migratorias más
transitadas para llegar a Europa 2023
podría llegar a ser el año más mortífero
para los migrantes en el Mediterráneo
desde 2016 un mar calificado de
auténtico cementerio humano por varias
organizaciones repasemos algunas
portadas aquí en Francia la coa titulaba
atrapados en la trampa y subrayaba el
poder que han adquirido las redes
mafiosas que organizan estos flujos
liberación con una portada que dice todo
es un fondo marino y un titular su
cementerio la palabra vergüenza en todos
en varios idiomas de la Unión Europea en
la portada de este diario griego Bueno
es un tema que siempre Vuelve que Europa
no soluciona que Cumbre tras Cumbre
aparece que casi ya asumimos que
desaparece hasta que vuelve otra
tragedia y volvemos a gritar vergüenza
Es que así Alexandra como una especie de
bucle qué está fallando en este bucle
Bueno yo creo que falla la política
misma la concepción de la política misma
enfocada hacia la externalización de las
fronteras la criminalización de la
inmigración la detención migratoria y la
expulsión de migrantes es el enfoque
mismo de la política el que fracasa y a
pesar de que fracasa seguimos
insistiendo en el mismo año tras año
entonces no es nada diferente de lo que
hemos estado viendo hoy día son estas
embarcaciones en 2013 era incendios en
moria digamos todo fragos náufragos en
otras en otras partes entonces lo que
fracasa es el enfoque y el que la
concepción misma de la política que
busca solamente la criminalización de la
inmigración y fracasa en su intento de
evitar a toda Costa la inmigración Diana
en que está fallando
Considero que las políticas públicas
actuales se formulan para hacer frente o
mejor como lo decía Alexandra para
frenar un poco estos flujos migratorios
Pero qué tal si nosotros analizamos
abordamos el tema desde el origen Cuáles
son esos factores adversos que obligan a
las personas a abandonar sus países de
origen Cuáles son esos temas de
desigualdades como nosotros podemos
tratar de apuntar mediante esas
políticas públicas a no resolver esos
problemas porque tal vez Es complicado
pero sí a tratar de mejorar estos
asuntos para disminuir esos canales por
ejemplo no sé aumentar las vías de
migración regular tratar de destinar
estas ayudas de la Unión Europea no para
esos países que son receptores o pasos
de migrantes sino para desarrollar
programas de formación de mano de obra
calificada acuerdos de cooperación
internacional sobre educación para que
estos migrantes cuando lleguen a estos
países lo hagan de forma regulada lo
hagan de forma ordenada lo hagan de
forma segura pienso que esto es una de
las fallas que se ve el problema Ya
cuando está en la puerta de la casa pero
tal vez si nosotros Tratamos de mirar
atrás se puede mejorar este esta este
asunto Pues que parece que vamos a golpe
de tragedia no se ve el problema hay una
tragedia hay una voluntad de hacer algo
que acaba en nada que va diluyéndose
hasta la siguiente tragedia no es como
una especie de bucle que ya hemos visto
un déjà Vu no es la sensación que
tenemos le vamos a preguntar a nuestra
corresponsal en Bruselas Esther Herrera
o en el fenómeno migratorio Esther es
uno de los más viscerales en el seno de
la Unión Europea y de los más divisorios
siempre consumen mucha energía coste
político cruce de reproches se acaba de
celebrar una Cumbre ahora en Bruselas se
mantienen esas divisiones en bloques
la política migratoria es quizás uno de
los temas más divisivos en la Unión
Europea Pero hay una voluntad muy clara
de
todo el mundo tiene recuerdos muy
vívidos de la crisis migratoria de 2015
y 2016 en que los bloques Entonces sí
estaban mucho más marcados que
actualmente había una gran desconfianza
entre todos los países y eso fue también
una de las decisiones que fue una de las
cuestiones que la hicieron fracasar Es
cierto que las divisiones más habituales
entre los países las vemos sobre todo
entre el bloque del Sur que generalmente
son los que más solicitantes de asilo
reciben y que piden pues más cooperación
del resto y también apoyo pero sin
embargo en las últimas semanas hemos
visto una gran voluntad de avanzar Y
aunque no todos países no todos los
países tienen la misma realidad se
coincide que en términos generales el
refuerzo de las fronteras exteriores es
uno de los puntos principales y también
en que es necesario llegar a un acuerdo
Entonces hay más voluntad que nunca y
quizás los bloques no están tan marcados
como como antes luego vamos a analizar
ese pacto migratorio que intenta la
Unión Europea Pero antes me gustaría
preguntaros por por la cartografía vamos
a ver si hacemos bien el diagnóstico
porque en 2023 casi 2.000 migrantes han
muerto ahogados intentando llegar a
Europa según la organización
internacional para las migraciones y
cómo es esa cartografía de la muerte es
decir cuáles son las rutas principales y
los perfiles para que nos entiendan
nuestros oyentes y espectadores bien
para ingresar a la Unión Europea hay
alrededor de siete rutas que se siguen
tenemos las rutas a través del
Mediterráneo y las que provienen tanto
de digamos el Mediterráneo central y el
Mediterráneo occidental pasando siendo
la del Mediterráneo central la más
concurrida aquella que pasa justamente a
través de Italia donde vimos el náufrago
en los últimos días pero también tenemos
aquellas que se dan es principalmente a
través de España pasando por el ansia a
través de ese auto y melilla o incluso
pasando Pues a través de España tratando
de ingresar aquella la que llamamos la
ruta del Mediterráneo occidental y
también pero no hay que olvidarse que
existen otras rutas que son menos
concurridas pero que también están allí
que son las rutas de los balcanes e
incluso una ruta circular que parte de
Albania pasa Grecia intenta ingresar a
la Unión Europea Pero quizás por eso
hablamos del Mediterráneo como un mar
cementerio teniendo en cuenta que la
gran cantidad de personas intentan
acceder sea por esta ruta del
Mediterráneo central pasando por Italia
pasando también por Malta o pasando por
Grecia o pasando a través de España
entonces es por esto que hablamos de esa
carga desproporcional de los países de
la periferia sobre el control migratorio
porque por las reglas de dublín uno y
dublín 2 pues son estos países los que
tienen la obligación de tramitar las
solicitudes de asilo de quien ingrese a
su territorio mientras que los demás
países pues tienen una afluencia mucho
menos grande de inmigrantes y para
precisar dentro de esta cartografía de
estas rutas quizá la situación interna
en Libia es la causante o el foco por la
que más estamos hablando de la ruta
central del Mediterráneo en estos
momentos Diana Sí realmente el caso de
Libia el caso de túnez que ya también
sus problemas internos sus conflictos
se ve exacerbado por el hecho de que son
Realmente están muy cerca a los países
de la Unión Europea Es decir de las
costas tunecinas hasta la isla de la
pedusa en Italia que sería el primer el
primer puerto de entrada de la Unión
Europea hay tan solo aproximadamente 150
kilómetros Entonces por esta razón es
uno de los pasos más concurridos de
personas migrantes es difícil esta
situación porque no existe una verdadera
gestión coordinada de las fronteras de
la Unión Europea y tampoco de esos
países que son receptores ya lo veíamos
como lo decía Alexandra los países por
ejemplo no sé de Marruecos o en la otra
parte del Mediterráneo central como
túnez y Libia es muy complicado si no
hay un sistema coordinado si no hay una
sinergia entre todos los países que ven
esta problemática porque de una u otra
manera cada uno va a actuar de manera
aislada y realmente no se va a poder
hacer frente a a estos flujos a estos
movimientos migratorios
en Bruselas porque claro siempre tenemos
países como Grecia o Italia que siempre
se quejan no se quejan en el seno de la
Unión Europea de la falta de solidaridad
del resto de miembros estos días en
Bruselas vuelve el tema a la agenda de
los líderes europeos Esther impide
avanzar de nuevo Esta división en
bloques esta falta de solidaridad de lo
que se quejan Italia y Grecia el pacto
migratorio lo propuso la comisión
europea hace ya tres años y tiene dos
focos principales en caso de emergencia
en que lleguen muchas personas en un
contexto de crisis automáticamente habrá
un repartido un reparto equitativo
voluntario entre los países para que la
acogida de personas no recaiga en uno
solo pero en un guiño a los países más
reacios a aceptar a solicitantes de
asilo Como por ejemplo Hungría o Polonia
se les ofrece la posibilidad de bien
pagar una cantidad de veinte mil euros
por persona al año para que otros países
se encargue de su o bien facilitar el
retorno de todos los personas que no
tienen derecho a asilo ahora mismo deben
empezar las negociaciones entre las
instituciones Por una parte están los
países que que ya han fijado su posición
Por otra parte está la eurocámara y
tendrán que empezar a negociar y llegar
a un consenso a principios de junio los
ministros acordaron un mecanismo de
solidaridad voluntaria Para repartir los
refugiados pero Hungría y Polonia de
nuevo votarán en contra para mostrar su
disconformidad veremos Cómo son las
negociaciones entre las instituciones
pero el objetivo es cerrar el pacto a
finales de año o a más tardar a
principios del año que viene será
seguramente bajo presidencia española
que toma ahora la presidencia de la
Unión Europea desde el 1 de Julio bueno
vemos que siempre la palabra solidaridad
es siempre la que aparece ahí los más
reticentes Polonia y Hungría que son
nombres que casi siempre salen bueno
Incluso se plantea imponer un pago de
hasta 22.000 euros por refugiado a los
países que rechacen su acogida o bien
participar en medios logísticos esto no
sé si vendría a ser acoger o pagar esto
sería el principio de solidaridad
obligatoria pero flexible al mismo
tiempo no sé si es un buen principio de
consenso Qué les parece Bueno hay que
recordar que no estamos frente a un
consenso ya de hecho es una vergüenza
que desde el 2020 estemos intentando
discutir el mismo texto que no hemos
podido llegar de acuerdo y si miramos
más para atrás recordemos la crisis
migratoria que mencionabas del 2015 y
como allí nos dimos cuenta como Pues el
reglamento de un lindo estaba
funcionando nuestro sistema el sistema
europeo de migración y estilo fracasa Y
entonces aquí nos damos cuenta que
estamos lejos de hablar de una respuesta
solidaria de los estados estamos
hablando de unos mecanismos que más que
activar la solidaridad buscan pasarse la
pelota de uno al otro para ver a quién
le toca la carga de la migración y
entonces Allí es donde vuelvo mi punto
inicial mientras la sigamos viendo como
una carga como algo de lo que nos
podemos deshacer al final resulta casi
como si pagáramos para que otro
dejara dejara morir a las personas
finalmente se trata de externalizar El
dolor externalizar la solidaridad lo que
no creo que sea posible
no sé qué le parece Usted ese principio
de solidaridad obligatoria pero flexible
Bueno este principio de solidaridad está
integrado en otros mecanismos
internacionales y lo más preocupante
aquí no solamente es que se vea como un
principio de solidaridad flexible sino
que ya existen unos instrumentos
internacionales que han sido
lastimosamente no totalmente tenidos en
cuenta para La regulación de este de
esta situación migratoria por ejemplo
existe el pacto mundial para las
migraciones de la ONU de 2018 en el cual
los países reafirmaron su compromiso de
respetar los derechos humanos de todas
las personas migrantes esto podemos
preguntarnos Qué sucede al día de hoy
Qué sucede en el Mediterráneo porque no
ha causado ese impacto este instrumento
tan importante dejemos esas preguntas en
alto porque me tengo que ir una breve
pausa pero enseguida las ponemos
respuesta a quien en Primera Plana hasta
ahora Bienvenidos a este espacio de
France 24 dedicado al medio ambiente
calentamiento global especies en
extinción destrucción de bosques
contaminación la tierra enfrenta muchas
amenazas este año la reunión de Naciones
Unidas fue el termómetro para medir qué
tan comprometidos están de cara al
acuerdo de París pero también surgen
ideas innovadoras y soluciones
sostenibles
semanalmente hablamos de los temas que
afectan a nuestro único hogar
acompáñeme en medio ambiente en France
24 y France 24.com
la guerra está a las puertas de Europa y
recuerda horas sombrías de la historia
la comunidad se ha organizado para
darles ropa
France 24 está pendiente de los
acontecimientos en Ucrania
con nuestros equipos En el terreno Y
desde nuestros estudios lo mantenemos al
tanto
siga informado siga al día
liberte egalité actualité seguimos esta
semana en Primera Plana analizando el
reto migratorio en la Unión Europea a
partir de la Cumbre que se ha
desarrollado en Bruselas y de la
presidencia española de la Unión Europea
que arranca este 1 de Julio lo hacemos
con Alexandra Castro consultora en temas
migratorios Diana kristacho fundadora
del gabinete de consejo faro para
migrantes y refugiados y desde Bruselas
nuestra corresponsal Esther bueno el
nuevo reglamento que tiene dos patas la
gestión de asilo y procedimiento de
asilo también avala la creación de
centros para migrantes y de
instalaciones de detención en las
fronteras de los estados miembros o en
territorio de tránsito mientras se
tramita la acogida o se decida la
repatriación no sé Diana está inquieta
las organizaciones porque se piensa que
es copiar el modelo de centros de las
Islas griegas cómo funciona Sí en efecto
Este modelo realmente es una copia de lo
que ya existe que vemos que no ha
ofrecido ningún tipo de solución porque
lo que se hace es crear unos centros de
retención un poco dejar en en una laguna
administrativa a todas las personas que
se encuentran en ese proceso de
solicitar el estatus el beneficio
Internacional del Refugio para ser
declarados como beneficiarios del asilo
es complicado que estos modelos que no
están funcionando se reproduzcan porque
realmente no van a ofrecer ninguna nueva
respuesta a estos problemáticas vemos
que esto viene desde hace mucho tiempo
se han creado diferentes tipos de
Procedimientos los cuales no han
funcionado muchas estrategias nuevas que
vienen a ser realmente más de lo mismo
es muy complicado en ese sentido Porque
también se están disminuyendo los plazos
de estudio para todas esas personas que
solicitan el estatus de refugiados
debido a unas u otras razones lo cual
impide un estudio profundo de esas de
esos casos que llegan y lo que se hace
Es que se se ordena un retorno casi que
inmediato de muchas de esas personas es
muy complicado y realmente la invitación
con todo respeto sería que analizarán
tal vez una nueva estrategia una nueva
estrategia político económica que
permitiera verdaderamente un estudio de
esos casos
una situación administrativa Tal vez un
poco más decente para todas las personas
que llegan como migrantes a estas a
estos puertos fronterizos en el
rompecabezas del reto de los flujos
migratorios para la Unión Europea no nos
podemos olvidar de hablar de las mafias
Alexandra Cómo actúan las mafias Y cómo
han aumentado su poder en los últimos
años como señalan tantos actores sobre
terreno Bueno yo creo que todo está
conectado cierto las mafias actúan son
directamente proporcionales al aumento
en las barreras en la migración regular
me explico en la medida en que las
personas necesitan salir de su lugar de
origen porque tenemos que partir a la
base y a veces se nos presenta la
migración como una cuestión de la
oportunidad de las personas o la
búsqueda de una mejor vida pero
recordemos que hay muchas de las
personas que migran que lo hacen por
necesidad y por necesidad No solamente
huyendo de guerras y conflictos sino
necesidad en Casos de hambruna en Casos
de violencia generalizada muchos
escenarios Entonces necesitan encontrar
la forma de huir como lo haría cualquier
ser humano en las mismas circunstancias
pero ante la ausencia de canales
regulares de migración ante una política
cada vez más restrictiva en materia de
asilo porque hay que recordarlo y perdón
que me devuelva un poco hablábamos del
pacto migratorio pero es que no
necesitamos un pacto que no sea
vinculante para recordar esto recordemos
simplemente las convenciones de Ginebra
sobre refugiados y el principio no
devolución y la prohibición de las
devoluciones en caliente entonces ante
un escenario hostil para la migración
los migrantes necesitan pasar por
terceras personas que los hagan llegar a
sus lugares de destino y ante las
digamos los controles cada vez más lejos
una externalización cada vez mayor de
las fronteras entonces tomamos rutas
cada vez más creativas más inventivos
tomamos botes cada vez más pequeños en
condiciones cada vez más adversas y hay
siempre entonces mafias personas que se
van a lucrar de esta dinámica migratoria
que lo que van a hacer es encontrar
caminos para hacer pasar estas personas
con digamos aún les toca pagar
cuantiosas sumas de dinero es un viaje
bastante costoso para ellos porque les
toca digamos pasar al lado de esos
controles migratorios para intentar
llegar entonces efectivamente existen
unas mafias de traficantes de migrantes
Pero ojalá no tendremos el foco en los
traficantes de migrantes sino en las
causas en las las cuestiones el contexto
que facilita el accionar de estos
traficantes y es la ausencia de canales
regulares de migración hablando de esas
causas de las principales causas de
desplazamiento humano a través del
mediterráneos bueno los conflictos
políticos hemos hablado también de las
crisis económicas sin embargo cada vez
hablamos más de otra de la crisis
climática que está convirtiéndose en
otra de las razones que ya debemos
plantear en casi en todos los foros el
clima extremo que puede reforzar además
esta tendencia No sí se ha llamado mucho
la atención sobre el tema de las
migraciones climáticas denominadas así
por algunos expertos y es importante que
se haga un énfasis en esta situación
porque tal vez se centra la conversación
únicamente en el tema económico en las
crisis en los conflictos sin embargo por
ejemplo podemos evidenciar como un caso
sirio donde la falta de acceso al agua
potable ha endurecido y ha hecho más
compleja la situación del conflicto
interno que ya se vive esto ha
ocasionado que se den muchas más
migraciones forzadamente lo cual es
complicado esto solamente para nombrar
uno de los casos pero en África por
supuesto que tiene una gran cantidad de
personas que migran hacia el continente
europeo se evidencian muchas de estas
situaciones el cambio climático muchos
desastres naturales también falta de
acceso al agua potable aún más
endurecimiento sobre el tema el clima el
tiempo esto también genera a que la
agricultura que los temas de
alimentación la producción local de
alimentos se vea disminuida o se vea
afectada o impactada es muy complicado y
yo pienso que estos temas deben estar
forzosamente incluidos dentro de las
conversaciones dentro de la formulación
de políticas públicas y dentro de estos
nuevos pactos que se quieran realizar
para abordar el tema de la migración
volvemos junto a Bruselas con estrer a
nuestra corresponsal bueno el fenómeno
migratorio Esther es uno de los más
divisores como ya hemos comentado de la
Unión Europea arranca la presidencia
española del bloque este primero de
julio antes de las elecciones europeas
del año que viene para posicionar todo
el escenario Porque se ve tan
trascendente esta oportunidad de la
presidencia española para cerrar el
pacto migratorio la reforma migratoria
es como bien dices un tema muy divisivo
la anterior reforma es el conocido como
reglamento de dublín de hace 10 años
pero que ha demostrado que no funciona
en este reglamento se decide que una
persona debe pedir asilo en el primer
país europeo al que llega Qué pasa que
en 2015 se intentó tomar una medida de
emergencia en un momento en que muchas
personas provenientes de serie
Afganistán llegaron a Europa a pedir
asilo pero el sistema colapsó Grecia
Italia tenían infraestructuras que no
podían acoger a tantas personas las
personas se encontraron una situación
deplorable que ponía en riesgo su
dignidad humana y situación la comisión
europea propuso unas cuotas obligatorias
de reparto de migrantes entre los países
pero el sistema fracasó prácticamente
ningún país cumplió con sus compromisos
la propuesta actual vista de ser
perfecta pero ha conseguido más consenso
también es una propuesta muchos más
amplia que también
espera también reforzar Los lazos la
cooperación con los países de origen
Como por ejemplo túnez Egipto y también
en Libia se considera que esta es la
mejor propuesta y que si no sale
adelante es muy difícil que en el futuro
lo haga porque hay que tener en cuenta
que las elecciones al parlamento europeo
son el año que viene y puede tener una
composición totalmente distinta en que
la extrema derecha pueda ser mucho más
importante sea mucho más fuerte y se
considera que muy probablemente una
propuesta así no pueda salir adelante
con una composición distinta del
parlamento europeo
claro hablaba Esther de esa
coyuntura no de las elecciones europeas
de esa posibilidad de la extrema derecha
Claro porque Europa grita vergüenza cada
vez que vemos una tragedia en el
Mediterráneo pero luego la mano dura
cada vez está en más programas políticos
cotiza el alza Cómo se explica esta
aparente paradoja bueno
el editor en jefe de Human decía que lo
asimilaba mucho con lo que pasa en
Estados Unidos con los tiroteos verdad
en donde todo el mundo sale a decir una
vez más un tiroteo terrible pero luego
la política sigue igual aquí vemos
Exactamente lo mismo Me permito recordar
que en el 2013 cuando también ocurrió en
lampedusa una tragedia Pues el
presidente del Consejo en ese momento de
la comisión Perdón Decía es una
vergüenza prometemos que esto nunca va a
pasar hoy en día vuelve a ocurrir una
tragedia y la y La respuesta es ni
siquiera es bueno es una vergüenza es
tre Pero vamos a seguir
insistiendo la política que ya sabemos y
que finalmente lo único que hace es
acabar con las vidas hablaba Esto hace
un rato que no ha cesado el número de
personas que han llegado entonces
insisto en la misma política que me
cuesta mucho dinero hay que recordar que
el presupuesto anual de frontes que es
además de 500 millones de euros para
vigilar el Mediterráneo con la mayor
tecnología posible con el uso de drones
embarcaciones
aviones con todo tipo de tecnología y en
todo caso fracasa Entonces al final es
el hecho de insistir en una misma
política enfocada hacia la
criminalización de la migración y el
migrante que fracasa y seguir
insistiendo en lo mismo lo que hace que
de ese mismo resultado
nos llevamos las manos a la cabeza
gritamos vergüenza y luego pedimos manos
dura en los programas electorales como
ves está aparente paradoja sí siempre
sucede que durante las campañas
electorales durante la época realmente
de la recolección de votos o de la
estructuración del voto si lo podemos
llamar así
se manipula un poco el discurso para que
los electores estén de una u otra manera
contentos agradables con la solución a
estas problemáticas una solución por
supuesto transparente basada en el
respeto de los Derechos Humanos de las
reglas internacionales etcétera y a la
hora de realmente ofrecer soluciones
para estos problemas lo que vemos es que
no se cumplen estos discursos realmente
es una manipulación de todos estos
contenidos de todas estas conversaciones
porque siempre está el tema mediático
porque siempre la prensa está allí
encima exigiendo soluciones lo cual es
un trabajo muy importante que ustedes
realizan pero en el momento de la verdad
siempre volvemos a estos mismos temas no
existe realmente transparencia a la hora
de abordar estos problemas por parte de
las autoridades políticas que se
encuentran a la cabeza de las
instituciones que deben gestionar estos
flujos migratorios Alessandra Diana Por
supuesto que no es un tema con un reto
como el migratorio soluciones mágicas no
hay pero
lo que sí hay soluciones populistas eso
Por supuesto pero si pudieran aconsejar
a los líderes que están estos días en la
Cumbre de Bruselas o incluso ahora que
se inicia la presidencia española qué
ejes o qué criterios por dónde deberían
ir unas soluciones razonables yo creo
que tenemos que más que luchar contra la
inmigración irregular debemos abordar la
migración de una manera integral
pensando efectivamente hay que controlar
las fronteras exteriores nadie dice que
no pero tenemos que con la misma fuerza
con los mismos recursos y con el mismo
ahínco luchar por la integración de los
migrantes y luchar contra la
discriminación y la xenofobia de la que
sufren los migrantes en los lugares de
destino si logramos la integración de
los migrantes va a lograr un mayor
bienestar para tanto ellos como para
todas las demás personas vamos a lograr
una mayor cohesión social que al final
es lo que busca la Unión Europea es el
bienestar de las personas que viven aquí
entonces si luchamos por una inclusión
por una integración de las migrantes con
la misma fuerza con la que vigilamos el
Mediterráneo vamos a conseguir el
bienestar para todos si vos cambios ese
eje en la política si dejamos hablar de
este discurso en el que vemos al
extranjero como una amenaza Y empezamos
a verlo como una oportunidad como hay
ejemplos en el mundo de que se ha hecho
creo que allí vamos a ser más
constructivos y vamos a dejar de
solamente llevarnos las manos a la
cabeza cada vez que mueren personas en
los barcos mientras por detrás seguimos
dando dinero para controlarlos los mares
y favorecer que estos bancos barcos se
hundan bien una sola frase porque me
quedo ya sin tiempo sujeto verbo y
predicado Yo pienso que es fundamental
trabajar en la minimización de esas
factores adversos que conllevan a las
personas abandonar sus países trabajar
de manera integral como lo dice
Alexandra aumentar las vías de migración
regular y una gestión coordinada de las
fronteras pues muchísimas gracias a las
tres ha sido un placer compartir este
tiempo con ustedes y a todos ustedes nos
encontramos aquí en Primera Plana la
próxima semana gracias